yeah whatever so Jeezy gz world two
catch me on the bootleg cab podcast
bootleg capture we got a special
oh Jeezy welcome sir what's the deal
what's up buddy good I gotta shout you
out because you set some uh
some like [__]
paintings well that was that what we're
calling them you sent like the little
canvases I got a couple of them yeah
that's why it's like they're like
collectors items right come on man yeah
Southern [__] in a few years yeah
whatever man uh how you feeling though
man you're obviously new project is out
that's a good man I've been torn
non-stop I'm kind of tired yeah you've
been on the road you was running around
the country in the cookies bus cookies
bus and a back-to-back tour so under the
cookie bus and I went straight to the
reading tour right after that was the YG
toy yeah the red cup tour yeah what was
that like it was amazing it was my first
Arena tour she was crazy it was a whole
different feeling whole different
experience is it like a little different
because you have like some pretty rabid
like insane fans
um is it and and you and YG share a lot
of fans of course we share a lot of fans
so damn near felt like it was my show
every night to fire yeah it didn't feel
like it didn't feel like I was doing
support it felt like I was headlining
was
yeah I think he was I think he popped
out on a few dates or something yeah I
was wondering if like there's like a
like a literal child running around
backstage you have to kind of watch
what's going on you know because like
that kid will hit me up because I had
him freestyle on my show and he'll hit
me up for weed and I'm like dude
you're a [__] child I can't do
nothing for you I'm not committing my
son is older than you I'm not giving you
weed bro
um who was on the new project oh my God
Kaelyn bino kamiyah
uh Tyga
okay no come on it's a whole lot of
calories uh Mozzy yeah all the homies
all the home girls beer B is on it yeah
I think I'm a remix every person that's
not from uh well B is not from over here
she's from Boston yeah
me and him got the heater going up yo
that Geekly yeah [__] raw and it's
crazy because I just had a cash kid on
my show maybe like two months ago that's
my boy he dropped one of the craziest
freestyles bro he'd be guessing look
that's why I put him on the [__] in the
first place because I was gonna say
because I'm I'm a big fan of cash kill
like I've always listened to Cascade
yeah he's super underrated are you
pretty like tapped in with the whole
Detroit scene yeah hell yeah I feel like
um
what's it called I went out there and
worked with almost everybody there is
from [__] Detroit yeah when I when I
first started the uh coming up with
Shoreline and everything so we were
dropping all the Detroit producers like
change your life one of one of my
biggest Shoreline songs I flew Hawaii a
hell of a out to Hawaii and we did that
[__] in Hawaii
yeah Detroit I feel like is like finally
starting to get disrespect yeah they're
going crazy right now too for sure and I
feel like musically they've always been
like some of the best [__] rappers I
grew up listening to the [__]
Doughboys cash out for sure shout out to
uh Giovanni and those guys sir
um but musically I don't feel like
Detroit like you know it's that same
tempo the type of Beats La gets on the
bay gets on you know um it's kind of
like it's a similarity between like Cali
and Detroit beats yeah for sure
um what's going on with uh with for you
like
I'm the last time you were here you were
talking about the Mariscos restaurant
you're gonna yeah yeah you got the
Mariscos but you got the makeup [__]
going still right uh eyelashes yesterday
magic has makeup yeah I got eyelashes on
my website yeah you got so much things
that you're stupid I'm just been torn so
much I haven't even been focusing on
merch or nothing like I just made you
just been running around yeah did you
ever open up the restaurant yeah we did
how's it doing
um I don't I don't know if we moved
locations I was just a investor yeah
your mom like helping run it no no no my
mama runs my merch okay Mom runs the
merch shout out to Mom and she goes on a
tour with me she does my virtual tour as
well so she's been she was on the red
kill toward me and she was on all my
shoes on all my toys what's it like
having your mom tour with you though
almost against this little your mom's
cool yeah close foot yeah I mean you're
in a relationship you ain't cutting off
too much it's like having the homie
right yeah and it's someone you trust
running your merch and [__] running all
this [__] make sure the numbers is right
like she she damn near like a sales
because she trying to upsell and do the
most for me for me so 100 man um you
grew up in Hollywood right yeah did you
go to Hollywood High yeah I did
grow like going to Hollywood High do you
ever just buy like proxy like walk into
a random Jimmy Kimmel performance as a
kid nah but I would see them like I
think they had like a stage set up
behind the uh like an outdoor stay set
up like by the PE field that's what I'm
saying like the stages right there I
would see I would see like performances
and [__] but I didn't even pay that [__]
no more is it crazy like seeing because
for people who don't know East Hollywood
is kind of like the more sketchier side
of Hollywood that's kind of where like
little Armenia is
um we think of Hollywood and we think
it's like Glitz and glamor
but it's really like a it's a dicey's
place it's a tourist trap you know what
I'm saying but like like the boulevard
is like all the touristy [__] then you
just go down over there and it's just
like regular I was gonna say that
Hispanic neighborhood is it like uh is
it crazy to kind of see
because Hollywood has gotten really bad
in the last since the pandemic like when
you're down there you're like damn this
[__] is [__] up over here like I feel
like it's always been the same what's
Got It Bad is like West Hollywood where
[__] where like uh where it was kind of
supposed to be safe because I saw all
the shopping and all that [__] but now
everybody getting robbed and everything
is bad it is kind of crazy are you like
pretty mindful about that type of [__]
when you're moving around like without
security keep the jewelry at the crib
yeah I need to wear my if I'm like
grocery shopping or something I'm
definitely not wearing no [__] shirt
yeah I saw you at the [__] Easter
farm with your girl and you had no
jewelry yeah I'm not wearing my [__] if
I'm going out if I'm kicking with my
family or something like yeah we had uh
some rappers come on yesterday from New
York these kids 41 and they put the
jewelry on right before the interview
started I was like oh you guys are smart
and like yeah I was walking around L.A
with all this jewelry on yeah la is
Jakey it is kind of crazy man
um how do you feel man like I feel like
when we think of like Latin artists man
you're kind of
um on the Forefront of like you know
guys who I feel like appeal to because
with you know when I was growing up it
was like MC Magic it was little Rob it
was guys like that who you know if you
listen to Little Rob he's
you know if you're like a A hip-hop head
you probably might not relate to his
[__] because it was some Chicano rap and
there was like guys like Capone and Mr
Criminal and all that [__] which was
like really like specific
Chicano [__] you know what I'm saying I
feel like you're just making Dope music
and you happen to be a Mexican dude you
know what I'm saying like but you are
kind of like the face of not for sure I
feel like I made uh everybody wanna rap
and and get in they baggie for me so I
mean I'm proud to be the damn near the
face of it like I don't know who else it
is yeah no it's I mean nationally I'm
like bro you got records that and you've
done records with just everybody yeah
like the baby that but the baby record
was so hard yeah so far yeah it's
definitely um not yet I'm doing music
with like all my [__] everyone I
listen to like idols and [__] yeah
exactly who was like the one artist that
you've worked with so far that was like
the biggest bucket list like
artist the song the song was whatever
not his versus fire but we just like I
don't know why we even picked that song
we had future on the song on the [__]
Shoreline album
and you it just didn't I feel like my
verse is like it was like a throwaway
song why the [__] how do you how do you
let it throw away song that's what I'm
saying I don't remember so the future
was on the record but it wasn't a record
like when you recorded the song you
didn't know future was gonna end up no
no no exactly I'd have been like nah
guys we got a code we got to go back in
here but you know what happened was that
uh that album was coming out when the
group was breaking up so it was kind of
like you know let's just get through the
contract yeah that [__] was like [__]
that up I don't know who the [__] put it
together but
um how's everything I mean what kind of
bag would it take to get you guys to
come back together to do like a one-on
bag a super bag it's Gotta because I
already make a bag
look at your jewelry I'm like I just
want to go get some New Jersey too but
yo I feel like maybe in like five years
if you guys did like a reunion tour it'd
be kind of like it'd be kind of crazy
not me tell you I'm not opposed to it we
just need that baggie for me because
it's like not like anything ever
happened to where you guys are like yeah
it'd have to be a good business movie
exactly exactly I respect that what
about to do an album uh well yeah the
same [__] we just get a bag man right in
that bag here would your bag have to be
bigger than everybody else's uh
it would make sense for so was that kind
of like a big reason like why what was
the nah because uh me and Phoenix was uh
it was everything was split 50 50. so
and then the the other homies was only
on like two three songs so right it was
really like you and Phoenix right yeah I
always wonder like when I think it was
just like it was just everybody wanted
to do their own [__] for real because
like Wu-Tang Clan I always wondered like
if you God gets the same bag as Method
Man you know I don't expect you to
really understand that reference
yeah okay he's the one that was in
charge right there no that's Rizza oh my
bad
bro you're [__] how old are you uh
I'm about to be 30. oh [__] bro I did
not know you're about to you're a grown
ass man I don't get old man what's [__]
what's fatherhood like for you man I
feel like I'm getting older and older
especially watching him grow up how old
is your kid now he just turned four damn
yeah he's big as [__] he's like the size
of like a seven-year-old he wears seven
year old clothes yeah it's like a real
ass dude right there running around your
house about to start kindergarten you
gotta be preschool uh nah you know the
preschool but he about to start
kindergarten I think he's about to start
preschool okay let me ask you this
because I always we always hear about
terrible twos but I always tell
everybody that three is the worst thing
no yeah he well not nah I feel like he
was cool I feel like right now at four
he's crazy he's turned just like
demanding [__] he's like yesterday I
took him to the Natural History Museum
because he kept asking to go he's like I
want to see fossils and butterflies we
walked outside to see butterflies
because the exhibit was on the outside
he thought we was leaving the [__] so he
was just in a butterfly [__] man the
whole time with his arms crossed and
he's like I want to go back inside I'm
like bro we in the butterfly thing he
just wasn't even looking at them he's
like I don't want to leave yeah I'm not
ready to leave yeah
he's just like diminished he's like I
want toys I want this toy he wakes up
watches YouTube he's like I want that
toy that tool what YouTube channels is
he into uh just like a bunch of um
what's that [__] called like educational
stuff man the YouTube [__] is crazy
sometimes my kids be watching [__] on
YouTube it'd be the cringiest [__] man
yeah he'd be he'd be watching stuff and
I should be having like 200 million
views yeah million views I'm like this
[__] crazy there's like this dude who
plays video games with this kid
and he's the most annoying [__] dude
ever
but I guess it works because he like
he's marketing it towards four-year-olds
so yeah shout out to your son man now
there's a bunch of random message he'd
be watching 100 like uh [__] watching
playground reviews and stuff like that
toy reviews playground like I just feel
like he my kid be watching other kids
play Minecraft I'm like bro what the
[__]
um so you got tag on the album you got
uh that was on the Chrome Heart song
right yes sir
uh you got Kalyn shout out to Kalin
that's what I want a boy how did you end
up blinking with beer for the remix
my manager linked me up with her already
should I worry
um and she was super cool she was like
she wanted to get on the song I think
she was actually at my Pomona show
[__] like four years ago or something
when I first came out she's been
following me on Instagram we've been
following each other so it was only your
time it was only right it was like a
no-brainer yeah
is that something she sends in are you
in the studio with her nah a sentence or
fire you and cash could work on that
originally together nah I had that song
I think I had that song for like two
years or something is it hard to get
like a [__] the freak a leak sample
cleared so that's why we never really
try to put it out I haven't made that
song two two and a half years ago and
then they're like yeah it's gonna be a
headache with the sample they're like
going and they don't have a hook they're
like we don't know if it's gonna like I
don't know if we want to [__] go
through it is it worth the headache if
they're yeah if it's not gonna be a
single right yeah yeah yeah but we
dropped in that [__] went crazy you have
to clear that through Little John or who
you have to clear the pretty Pablo huh
Jive
random dude like who does make music
anymore he always up what the [__] yeah
is that a little John B three months
that's a little John B right I don't
know no no no freak a leak it's freak a
leak Little John I don't think so I
don't think this is random dude I don't
know why I thought I don't know shout
out to PewDiePie
wait Petey Pablo's number's in his bio
and you call it and he answers
hey someone got her to redo that [__]
the North Carolina [__] the raise up the
baby should do let's just see for little
John right yeah Carolina yeah shot a
little John may that be I was like Hey
damn that was that everywhere everything
was just Lil Jon the crunk era man what
do you remember about the crunk era bro
I remember all this [__] I was listening
to all that [__] he was like five bro no
was it I was like like 10 11. you were
probably you're probably seven or eight
I think I'm 36 and that [__] was popping
when I was like 13. it was popping I was
listening to it who's on your uh like
who's who's your give me your top three
or four favorite rappers ever man
I don't know you don't know I listen to
a lot of rappers it's all time uh
features for so future in the top uh
[__]
I don't know just future yeah I think I
listen to Future every day every single
day of your life yeah I listen to a
bunch of other [__] that's what I'm
trying to think
what'd you grow up listening to the most
uh girl listening to anything like Tupac
36 everything yeah
death what's your favorite Future album
I feel like I don't got a top top
nothing well what's your favorite future
price yeah 56 nights 56 nights it's
great yeah Firehouse project did it just
get put on dsps finally yeah I think
like a bunch of his mixes yeah I think
all the mixtape [__] has to think God
because so much of that [__] you had to
get the DAP piff app or go on YouTube
the pain oh God I used to live that piff
up shout out to the dead people I think
they just deleted that [__] or something
that's terrible like I think it just
like disappears all those mixtapes just
you gotta go on YouTube and listen to
shitty quality versions oh God crazy yo
what's good man we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our good
Folks at my bookie that's right man NBA
season is uh winding down playoffs are
going down so many ways you can get
money you could bet on who you think's
gonna win the finals you can get your
prop bets per game uh we are finally
down to the final eight right now uh my
sons ain't looking good at the time of
recording not looking good uh look go to
mybookie.ag right now sign up
I've been gambling on my Boogie for over
10 years so listen come and join me
let's get this money together
mybookie.ag when you use the promo code
bootleg when you sign up use that promo
code you're going to get that deposit
bonus that deposit bonus is craziest the
sign up bonus you get and uh not only
are basketball football which is
starting to creep up on us baseball's
back MLB baseball man all season long
you get this money plus they got the
online casino if you're into craps
Blackjack roulette [__] slot machines
whatever it is go to mybookie.ag right
now use that promo code bootleg and get
that free deposit bonus that's how we're
doing things all right also I want to
give a big shout out to the homies of
King Palm man these are our new sponsors
at King Palm now this is the thing about
these King Palms man these things right
here
ah natural natural leaves free of
tobacco and additives the only thing I
smoke out of and what's dope is they got
these other ones right these uh this is
one of their more popular items right
here
great flavor
these are the leaf rolls they hold a
gram each and they got the terpene fused
tips which means you squeeze and you pop
the tip while you're smoking your flour
and you get a little burst of flavor
these are the peach pineapples
um they got the energy drink flavor they
got blue blueberry watermelon all kinds
of [__] man
um so what's dope if you go to
kingpom.com and use the promo code
bootleg cab right now you're gonna get
half off half off
half off kingpom.com tobacco free
natural
raps all right and also don't forget if
you're in a I don't know wherever you're
at go to 7-Eleven they got them your
local smoke shop one of the most
successful uh businesses in the game
when it comes to the all-natural Leaf
the most successful no tobacco no
nicotine just natural Leafs to stuff
your flour in and in case you did not
know they also have
whatever size King Palm this is
this is a giant Leaf wrapped around yeah
wrapped around some premium can I buy
shout out to uh King pump go follow one
more time kingpound.com promo code
bootleg Kev say 50 off let's get back to
the interview dude did you guys ever
have that where you had like a bunch of
like [__] that because you guys really
started off on Soundcloud was it pretty
easy did all that [__] end up on the
dsps or was there any like songs that
kind of fell through the cracks um a
bunch of songs did it like and even the
um I would have never pushed it on dsps
when I met mother my first managers
[__] T Camp Picasso they put the the
shoreline dude actually mixtape on
[__] dsps fire so I all I ever
thought it was like SoundCloud I didn't
even know how to upload a YouTube or
nothing
um Greedo just got out shout out to
Greedo I was just with him uh two days
ago I just shot a video of him yeah
shout out to him for his song uh no for
the [__] I got on the project okay uh
it's a games with me him and bino uh
obviously TK's burritos manager used to
manage you
um how dope is it to kind of see him
come out because yeah I think we kind of
like didn't know how long it was going
to be gone you know God even even when
he was coming out it was like a surprise
yeah it was like damn he's out and he's
in Texas
um how like just talk about your
relationship with him like obviously you
know I feel like he's I feel like him
and Draco are and you guys very
influential and everything happening so
I know me and him was just talking about
it when I seen him the other day because
we haven't seen each other in [__]
years right that was the first time
we've seen each other and we were just
talking about everything how we changed
everything and uh yeah that's my boy
that's like me and him got a real
friendship right yeah I feel like we me
and my boy Salas were just talking about
just like there's guys in La whose
influence is so crazy that like if you
aren't from here you really don't have
like any idea you know
not for real it's almost like people in
like the bay yeah
I don't think I think you kind of got to
be from debate I understand like the Mac
Dre thing like fully so that's the same
thing with Greedo and I I mean you guys
you guys have some crazy world tours
are you going to be uh
for this album are you
you know going crazy on the content
going crazy on the videos yeah we doing
uh I'm gonna try to shoot as many videos
as this label gonna [__] give me
money to shoot right so I don't shoot as
many of those and then the concept we do
another Tick Tock and [__] I feel like
I'm getting the hang of tick tock right
now how do you get the hang of tick tock
because this is [__] it's the I hope
they ban it I guess just using it my
Tick Tock going crazy right now I think
I got like 300 400 000 followers in the
last two months are you doing your own
tick tocks uh the label is helping me
with it but we kind of just piecing
together my own content that me and my
[__] camera got shoot so are you
hoping to get spanned too so it's one
less thing you have to work no hell no
because now I got it going I just like
now if you got deleted from the world
I'm like thank God I feel like Tick Tock
is changing the whole [__] music for
good or bad for bad yeah I feel like
it's all types of people getting popping
off one song and just like
and then they sign a deal for a single
and then they go away yeah yeah it's a
bunch of tick tock is crazy it's crazy
because then you got guys like yourself
who like are kind of like
backward reversing yeah I'm trying to
figure out already popping yeah I'm
trying to figure out how to get more
positive
yeah no what is it if you could give
anybody any advice about Tick Tock what
kind of content should they be doing if
they're up until I don't know I need to
learn what kind of content well you got
[__] 300 000 followers something
you're doing is working I'm just posting
like random [__] I'm already like an
established artist I feel like you are
so it's just like everything's just
adding to my to my [__] yo would you and
YG why'd you do the whole album with
mozzie you got share management would
you why'd you ever do a project together
uh uh I would be doing oh yeah we got to
do some rest of that [__] do you guys
have a bunch of unreleased music
together no no that would be crazy yeah
it would be crazy the song me and him
got the big bad wolf that [__] was hard
as [__] I feel like you got y got to
take it back to like just read up that's
right yeah we gotta do some ratchet [__]
yeah so mustard mustard got to do it
muster guy yeah unless they got to do
that [__] 100 have you ever worked with
mustard uh yeah he did a trap house I
mean we did okay that [__] went good
that's crazy man shout out to muscle
[__] on the way to being Platinum
mustard is a one of them ones man
um any who else anybody else though
paneling production on this album uh I
got production from all types of people
on this one
I'm trying to think I don't even
remember I was just getting everybody
was just sending me [__] in so you're
just like [__] it I'm not yeah you know
what that's I like that and I was also
you know I did a lot of this album on
tour on the bus yeah on the bus I did
something in the Green Room like all
attention you're recording agreement
yeah shit's crazy
what kind of mic you taking on the road
uh I don't know what type of what type
of mic I got oh I'm annoyman Neumann you
87 I have no idea I think the u87 that
sounds familiar that's funny
um yo so talk to me about like uh you
know for you man I do feel like
when we look at like the landscape of La
hip-hop
I think you've done a really good job of
branching out and like working with
people outside of the region and like
kind of breaking through because I do
feel like a lot of Cali rappers like you
listen to the music and you'll kind of
recognize that there is like kind of
like a ceiling on like the type of [__]
they're doing or the type of artists
that they're working with for you was it
like always like a conscious decision
for you to kind of like expand outside
of Cali in terms of like networking
doing records with people to kind of
make sure you didn't fall into that lane
where you're just I feel like it wasn't
like a conscious decision I just I just
did like what I like and I make music
with the people that I listen to you
feel me so I always listen to [__] from
every other reason and every other place
in the world so that was that's how that
went yeah
um who's who's somebody because I feel
like you're kind of always up on the new
[__] who's somebody who's popping who's
like you know that you're you're [__]
with it that maybe the rest of the world
ain't up on who's the most let me see I
[__] with uh bro that's coming out of
here [__] from the West Coast uh busy
he hard yeah he's dope shout out to uh
he's from San Bernardino right I don't
know where are you from yeah he's from
the I think he's from now that's the guy
who canceled on us like three times yeah
it's a b from Detroit he goes crazy he
go crazy have you heard this dude big X
the plug from Dallas no [__]
he's hard bro I gotta listen have you
heard him bro he's fired if it was super
crazy you know him busy I think he's
from uh he's from no he's from San
Bernardino this was somewhere out here
yeah for sure yeah
um what else is going on though man you
uh you're trying to get in some [__]
acting or anything uh [__] I'm not
opposed to it I'll do this [__] yeah
yeah talk about get some acting lessons
yo before you leave the house how do you
get the [__] hair perfectly no I
can't even tell you I gotta sell that
[__] what's that what's the hair hack no
trip man I gotta get the product
together and then when I got it together
and I'm selling it come on do you do
your hair before or after the Hat song
I'm gonna throw my little proud again
before before the Hat it's almost like
it's perfect it is perfect
would you ever cut your hair it's your
signature maybe maybe yeah maybe like a
few years a few years yeah yeah uh
what's your latest tattoo you got man uh
I got this joint it's my baby mama
oh wow that was uh the young lady I met
yeah shout outs here how long have you
guys been together
like going on nine years nine wow
where'd you guys meet
um we just met the mutual friends so we
started talking on like social media I
think like Facebook or something back in
the day Facebook you guys are on
messenger yeah so [__] like that and now
she's tattered on your [__] arm yeah
I got her lips right here too so let me
ask you something with the lips thing
was that her idea or your idea no that
was my idea you were like hey babe right
here
she's got to feel great she's like I got
my lips and now my face is on this
[__] arm he ain't doing nothing crazy
anybody try to take you out of getting
her face tattooed on your arm no I've
been with her for so long like nine
years no that's great mother of my child
what are you getting on the other side
I'm gonna get a bunch of portraits I'm
getting my homies that passed away all
types of [__] yeah
you still talk to Phoenix at all uh I
think we talked the other day he hit me
up and he was like yo he was telling me
about one of the songs how he [__]
today oh that's dope yeah shout out to
Phoenix he's a good guy yeah shut up bro
yeah I'm glad I'm glad y'all are still
are still chopping it up and talking
um anything for you like
being on tour as much as you've been on
how the [__] do you end up with burner's
bus uh everybody [__] with me man
we did a collab too that [__] went crazy
oh yeah no the cookies collab was crazy
for sure yeah you guys did uh oh yeah so
we needed a bus and burn is just like
the big humming he was like we couldn't
even get a bus we was trying to rent a
bus so we couldn't even pay for a bus
like all the bus everybody was on the
road or something at the same time so
there was no chance we could get a bus
and then we uh asked Vernon we was like
you think we borrow your bus he's like
yeah [__] it you gotta pay for that no
he didn't borrow it I mean it's kind of
free marketing for him right I don't
know he's just a good person he also
doesn't fly much to that burner yeah I
think he uses his bus to go everywhere I
don't like flying over either really
yeah what's wrong hey flying I hate just
going through the airport process oh I'd
rather I'd rather drive for 10 hours
then
LAX is trash I just hate being on the
plane but Burbank is like Burbank is
cool you just walk under the bus yeah
yeah burner's bus is nice though yeah
it's nice actually damn near like a rose
racing do you have like a list of things
you can't do on the bus like look bro if
I'm gonna let you use my bus you can't
be [__] on here you can't just don't
be wild enough don't be [__] up be
respectful your mom's on the bus with
you yeah exactly you gotta treat it like
it's my bus I like that man yeah talk
about your friendship with Burner how'd
that start obviously you guys did the
clothing collab yeah he just hit me he
told me he [__] with my music and he he
just uh he seen me like uh doing the
dash [__] and [__] he say you respect
like how I'm moving [__] and we just
been cool I feel like you know berners
probably the closest
thing to a billionaire that you and I
both know that's that that's what I'd be
thinking I'm like yo this is probably
like this food's like it really damn
near like a [__] Jay-Z
he might I think when it's all said and
done
I think
yeah he was on the Forbes and I think
number four is like a shout out barely
man shout out cookies yeah the cookie
[__] is lit okay do you have your own
weed uh I had it I think I'm gonna I'm
gonna do some [__] are you a big smoker
no I'll be smoking like that we smoking
on occasion I'm smoking when I drink and
I drink when I do shows and [__] yeah so
you gotta stop drinking so you don't you
don't drink like this at home no me
either I was like I can't I can't just
drink I don't understand people who just
be at home just drinking at like 3 P.M
I'm like dude what the [__] at 3 P.M on
a tour like I got a show like right yeah
yeah before the show you want to get a
little loose but I got homies who'll
just wake up
and they'll just drink all day no I
can't I can't do that yeah I got too
much [__] to do exactly I got a kid I
might drive somewhere yeah exactly I
gotta drive everywhere it is summertime
if you're dealing with electric erectile
dysfunction Ed if you will maybe you got
stress at work
maybe you're tired of looking at the
same chick
maybe you just need a little pep in your
step
um you need to get on that blue too man
you don't need to do anything but it'd
be nice to have the option to so go to
bluetooth.com right now
use the promo code bootleg and get the
first month supply of blue chew for free
what is Bluetooth
well Bluetooth is a chewable gets
delivered to your door in a discrete
package no doctor's appointments no
doctor's visits and uh it has the same
active ingredient as Viagra
and Cialis
so we're talking about getting your dick
hard here in case that went over your
head you know it won't go over your head
once you take it I promise you that
Bluetooth also is uh incredible because
not only does it come in the blue
chewable flavor with the same active
ingredient as vibrancy house but it also
has a mint chewable flavor which is the
same active ingredient as Levitra all
right all this if you're questioning I
don't know I don't want to spend no
money on does this [__] work look yes it
works and you don't have to spend money
if you use the promo code bootleg at
bluetooth.com because it's going to get
delivered right to your house they're
going to give you a month's supply for
free you just got to pay five dollars
shipping that's it the bluetooth's
coming to your house no awkward doctor's
appointments
no awkward doctors visits it's all
online
bluetooth.com Thank Me Later what's up
guys hey um if you are watching this and
it's April 20th 4 20
I'm gonna be hanging out at hardean
today
that's right put the flyer up The Rock
I'll be at hardeen um hanging out all
day today
um the craziest most just luxurious
illest dispensary in the world located
right in Los Vegas Nevada now Hardy in
Las Vegas they are our family they
sponsor the podcast I love those guys
dearly and when I say that it is the
best place I've ever walked into to buy
premium cannabis I'm not lying best
customer service
best bud tenders best bud
to put in your King Palm
and uh just overall man just a great
experience um so uh what y'all need to
do is go follow them online hardean
underscore Las Vegas follow them on the
gram
we got a lot of dope stuff in the works
they actually just opened a a fire
podcast studio so we're gonna be doing a
lot of content in Vegas
live from Hardin they also just dropped
a [__] tennis shoe with Fila they got
dope flag gear
um man premium cannabis the best
selection
culture
sniff you walk in that man listen they
got I'm not even lying to y'all Harding
has their own signature scent and it
smells good I keep a bottle of it in my
car literally maybe twice a day I spray
that get that hard eating whiff smells
amazing so look make sure you go to
hardine uh if you're in Vegas get in
that Uber get in that cab as soon as you
touch down say take me to hardine the
taxi drivers the Ubi drivers they know
exactly where it is because it's the
hottest spot in Vegas they go take you
straight there you're gonna tell them I
sent you they're going to get you
situated real nicely all right Harding
underscore Las Vegas go show them some
love go to hardinglasvegas.com gotta
give a shout out to our oh geez my dogs
had Odd Socks baby they've been [__]
with us from day one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butt-head socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead oh
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout
at oddsoxofficial.com using the promo
code bootleg so go right now
otsoxofficial.com my first uh suggestion
would be get you a pair or a pack of the
Odd Socks Basics the black and the
whites those are my go-to's and then you
gotta [__] with some of these Big
Lebowski socks
and they just got Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bro what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview
um what's uh for you man uh you've got a
lot of jewelry you spent a lot of money
on yeah have you have you regretted any
of these purchases no no because I'll be
I'll be handling my business first I
just bought a uh so I just I just went
[__] put in an order for my new kid
but I bought a new house last year a new
one in November because you I think the
last time we talked to you had a house
in like the valley somewhere but I think
you had just moved out yeah so you
bought another house so how many houses
you got now two two of them both in L.A
chunky [__] chunky [__] so you so this
this new one you bought is like the big
big one so what do you do with the old
one you ran it out no I still got it no
I'm saying you're running it tonight I'm
renovating the new one so I'm still in
there oh so you're in the old one while
the new one gets renovated when you get
into the new Trucking I don't know what
I'm gonna do with it dude ran it out
yeah I'm gonna do something find some
tenants throw it in there it's passive
income my renter just give it to a
family family member so yeah I mean if
they really need it yeah you know you
should start buying some houses like
that no I want to get I want to get in
real listening for so that's like my
main goal go any bro the LA's got the
worst tenant loss you be uh you be uh
doing real estate not here what's up put
me on game let's get into one let's go
ahead Eric over there he's got a house
in Fayetteville North Carolina he's
right now let's go have fun you got to
go to Phoenix which is like your second
home at this point I feel like you're
always a club you're always in AZ I feel
like my boys are always like Dario my
guy Dario's always booking for After
parties I'm like God this [__]
for a minute last year for sure
everywhere you know where I was at a lot
I was in Toronto a lot really yeah
what's Toronto like uh that's just
amazing I love Toronto hey [__] with you
out there they love me in Toronto really
I wouldn't I'd be out what's bad I've
never been I heard it's crazy what the
food is fire I got I got a bunch of
homies in Toronto like uh pressing them
all the homies from out there so when I
get out there it's like it's damn near
feel like I'm in L.A you had a show it's
like a coder did you have a show in
tomorrow yeah yeah and I think I did
like three four shows and Toronto last
year that's crazy bro I did not know
was amazing
yeah wrong is weird though man I feel
like I got that like viral video where I
bring my mom out she dancing
oh [__]
that's what's up it shows Craig shot
what is the for outside of Cali what's
your biggest Market
um that's my biggest one I don't know my
biggest Market because I mean everywhere
I go should be sold out and turned
through so let's be nice
I don't know which one's the biggest
what's your favorite song of This Album
man
um
Top Model Top Model might be one of my
favorites is that just you yeah it's
just me produced by the load of great
okay for you like uh
are you super tapped in on like the the
new the new La [__] like I just saw um
shout out to some you know obviously
blue bucks is doing their [__] thing
yeah I saw on that on that tour where I
had the cookies bus I took uh blue books
with me right they were on tour but
they're doing a whole album with Draco
that's all right yeah that's just crazy
I'm gonna do a whole project with them
too with Draco no uh with blue box for
sure is this confirmed you and blue
books are doing album together we damn
near started like half of it on tour
really
when's that coming out
we gotta finish it we be busy is it
harder for you to do this since we got
back from the tour we haven't even been
able to [__] well listen you guys are
both on major labels yeah so they're on
Capitol you're on Atlantic is it a lot
harder to pull off something like that
when you guys are on major labels I
don't know because like once once we do
it I mean they'll figure it out you feel
me the label's gonna figure it out we
just got to [__] it's harder to do it
because we're so busy and then busy I'm
busy I haven't been back home like since
I did the tour with them I went right
back on another tour the YG [__] and
I'll be having all shows and [__] in
between and you got to do the YG album
yeah I got to do that too honestly I
feel like you and cash care would do
some crazy [__] too yeah I just send
some more [__] to cash kids he's so hard
yeah I said so of course it's 100 man
well like the new album is out you can
search easy world too a bunch of crazy
features on it yeah
um why do the sequel to the original
um I just had to I feel like it was a
finish you know when I when I turned in
the first Deluxe on the first one too
yeah but I feel like the Lexus gets
slept on like
originally it was like a big deal like
when Uzi did the deluxe and like kind of
I don't listen to Noah's Deluxe even if
I'm listening to the original album I'll
go look for the deluxe so I know for a
fact [__] deluxes get slept on and
then
um we had only put 11 songs on the
original and there was a bunch of songs
I wanted to put on so you know I saw
this one I think we came 21 22 songs in
it hey have has your management or your
uh label try to get you to do reggaeton
yet but I've always wanted to do some
[__] I feel like if you should hop on
somebody [__]
yeah exactly I've always wanted to do
some regular [__] I've always said that
bro you be in [__] Colombia yeah I'm
gonna go out to Puerto Rico and work
with everybody
I'm gonna go work with everybody I was
gonna say you've you're kind of like uh
unofficial king of Rosarito I feel like
I've seen you too I've seen it too
what's the name of that spot out the
resident I got a residency Papas and
Beer right yeah bro you be out there all
the [__] time hey were you out there
when the uh cartel was [__] [__] up I
think I was there that's like last year
wait I think I'm not sure it was like
one of those big weekends and it was
something no no I wasn't I wasn't
because they had like a regular Thumb
Festival that weekend yeah there was a
festival I've seen I seen and at least
go cartel was [__] TJ up and I was
like my boy the channel was out there I
was like [__]
you get nervous when you go to Mexico no
because they do like the most they they
uh bring us escort us to the whole [__]
you ever hang out in TJ like go eat they
got the best food let's go do my show
guys you got it you got it you gotta go
get some ice cream
I've never been to um
bro go to Cancun they got the inclusive
resorts
which is you know you go and they just
everything's included
restaurants yeah take your girl man just
so where do you and your girl vacation
at oh [__] I feel like I don't really
vacation like that I don't like don't
say big bear no I don't like I don't
like to go on vacation unless I'm
getting paid so the last vacation was
like Hawaii or something like because
you were getting paid because I go to a
show and then I get to relax man you
gotta relax man I'll be working too hard
you got to unplug for like 10 days are
we working yeah so last time I went with
her to Hawaii I stayed there for 10 days
that was the longest I've ever been
somewhere in 10 days yeah which which
island uh Honolulu Okay okay I don't
think that's the name of the island by
the way I think that's the name of the
city oh I think it's is it is a Waikiki
I think that's the beach yeah look at me
oh wow bro you gotta [__] go to like
Cancun you got to go to like Costa Rica
I do got to go leave the four-year-old
with your mom she Puerto Rican so I
gotta go to Puerto Rico with her you
gotta take her back home to Puerto Rico
but has she ever been she in business
she was a kid oh yeah Puerto Rico and
you don't even need a passport today for
sure I gotta go you have a password of
course I Go Everywhere I got a password
they let you in Toronto which means you
can go anywhere yeah they had me in the
last time I went in Toronto they had me
at the border for like seven eight hours
really why though I had an open case oh
that was tripping on me I was like uh it
was a headache it was crazy so how they
end up letting you in Draco or something
um
what's it called most people don't get
in without I gotta I had a [__] um
like some [__] I paid for some extra
[__] I pay for Sentry Global Entry it's
not I forgot what it was called but I
paid some extra crazy amount and then
open case resolved yeah good for you
stay out of trouble you're good I didn't
even get in trouble misunderstanding I'm
not trying to get into your fight it was
a misunderstanding anyway man I
appreciate you pulling up uh I
appreciate yourself get the album uh you
don't even know if your restaurant got
moved yet or not so I would tell people
to go to the restaurant but you wouldn't
go I'm gonna get in real estate man
that's about to buy houses tons of
houses rent them out just straight out
of Cali bro it's too expensive here bruh
no God my new house is expensive as [__]
yeah you got the new chunky crib new
album merch eyelashes oh look when's the
merch is the merch already dropped for
the new album uh no I'm I'm taking like
a bunch of exclusive ass merch on tour
oh so you can't even buy the merch
unless you see so you're going on tour
again yeah shout out to you not taking
vacations yeah no Jesus right back on
the road when's the tour start uh
when this come out am I able to say it
and the bay wow
no brakes take a break no brakes oh
Jeezy I appreciate you ready yes sir yes
sir boom